[Music]
we're back we did it we took a bit of a
hiatus III I went to New York City and
you know you're all set on my but you're
so busy well at my desk working but yeah
we're file doing six ah yay yeah it's
been a while we're done with five which
you seem to be pretty happy about I am
I'm glad that it's over but it was fun
to play with you for the first time and
then in six we play together as well but
not until I finished the prologue which
I'm about to start because you have to
play that by your lonesome we can talk
about it more after the prologue but we
do have a plan for resmio 6 which people
were talking about in the resin go 5
finale we can talk about it while
playing the prologue because we people
were like how many are you gonna play
you can play all the campaigns you can
play some of the campaigns yes so we are
on the PlayStation menu we're gonna go
right into it alright cause I'm doing it
does not go to the menu first there's
the entire cast of this game oh my
playable cast bunch of good-looking
people yeah Jake is super handsome
didn't you say one of them was 16 I
forget sherry is it sherry Burke that
makes no comfortable
sherry Birkin I think it's sherry Bergen
no that's resonable revelations - yes
Jake's sidekick who was from an earlier
entering the game is that would actually
be oh they do have like a little bit of
a menu here it's nice but I remember we
were playing this before and like
there's no like you can't do anything
until you go through this prologue which
is so indicative of this game because
it's very restrictive it's like we will
let you know when you can do stuff enjoy
this movie yeah so it's not very long I
think it's like 15 minutes long wait no
what that's oh it's clear read the
sixteen-year-old
no no that's not
I think I'm looking at The Mercenaries
playable characters lists characters
here we go it is cherry Birkin okay I
was right
so Barry no William Birkin from
resonable - and [ __ ] my Laura's offer
now and his wife who ADA or Leon gets
that antidote thing from and - that you
kill mm-hmm it's dude who is responsible
for the virus in - that's his daughter
she's the one who helped escape through
the ducts before you escaped the police
office who station it's all connected
well they try
what I'm excited for this because I
think this game will actually be more
entertaining for viewers to watch us
play then five was because it's
cinematic it's just dumb I plan on
having a better attitude in general
because in five I got like really
despondent because the bosses were you
couldn't move like there were so many
bosses where you like had to be but now
I feel like we just get to run around
and be silly although there's a lot of
QuickTime events yes for people
wondering my playstation is on the menu
right now so we'll sort through the coop
once this prologue is through cracks I
was telling you before this marry is
this your joke no no no Mike told me he
had a really good joke oh you'll see
one of the good like the one of the few
good things about this intro stop is
that it sets a tone for the rest of the
game it's not like a survival horror ish
intro and then you get to the action
they just show right away we're [ __ ]
explosions helicopters obviously they're
Tarantino he'll go back in time out in
this book
leave it to Otto that was the name of my
school's mascot at Syracuse Auto wasn't
not her no he's an orange Otto the
orange so used to be Syracuse Orangemen
and that was a kind of sexist cuz
obviously we have a lot of really good
women's athletic teams also it was it's
pretty derogatory turd toward like
Native Americans and there's a lot of
Native Americans
what's an orange man the the logo itself
was like an orange skin colored Native
American just the Syracuse Orange
so you're just oranges no it's just be
orange like what does that mean what's
the orange I honestly don't know like
when like say there it's a big
basketball lacrosse school when they're
referencing the team on the field
they'll say the Syracuse Orange with six
goals not the oranges I honestly it was
just a reaction to it being a sexist so
wait you're a color I'm I don't
understand pretty much just go sonic
Florida we're not known for our oranges
don't feel like white wine and salt put
salt potatoes and chicken Speedy's I
guess I don't know oh my god sorry if it
bothers people I was talking over this
but there's not much going on press
circle to pay respects what I have to so
I thought you caught my great joke my
reference I'm doing getting a Greek
achieve the
the initial plan for resonable sick
because people were asking in the resin
whoa five finale comments so we were
talking for resonable - we just did Leon
a scenario and then we said maybe we'll
leave [ __ ]
I [ __ ] didn't do that right you got
it I shouldn't have I know
so be honest campaign is like all cuties
in this game ah great so for those who
don't know there are four campaigns
Leon's Chris's Jake Wesker's and ADA
Wong's which is like a shorter bonus one
almost but because we were saving like
Claire B scenario or who'd you play in
the first game Chris or Jill Chris right
Chris maybe Jill because Jill has an
extra slot yeah so like we were saving
those we our initial plan right now
because this is such a long resonable
game is to do Leon and Chris's campaigns
because those are the two characters
that like Mary you've seen throughout
this series so far
Jake Wesker is honestly kind of throw
away although it's close to Sheri but
but we also want to get to seven finally
and this game could get long if we're
gonna play through all four campaigns we
definitely wouldn't do a does but we
figured we could potentially throw it to
the comments and see how many people
want us to do all three campaigns
although like it just takes time away
from resi seven yeah which I'm so
excited to get to you still haven't
played it I'm really never played it and
I've avoided spoilers
I've liked I haven't watched
playthroughs of it and I wanted to and
I've heard some good things many cool
maybe not twists that game is one of my
favorite games of the year Oh it'll be
nice to get back to resonable games a
healing item we honestly haven't well
for I really like but it'll be nice to
get back to where as me will get my
super duper life but yeah so right now I
guess in the comments just maybe let us
know if you wanna see Jake's campaign
right now the plan is to do Chris and
Leon I think we'll probably stick to
that it's not like a lighting issue what
is it I was it like yeah I think it's
like glitchy no there are some of those
stuff in these remasters we already are
playing on a ps4
soldiers
Oh probably figured out by now this the
fancier version yeah rack up those
trophies well I guess you have my ps3 -
gimme gimme gimme
so I got a plant I like that they keep
it consistent they're still plants she
[ __ ] up what do you want attention
while he walks that's it Swagger's you
wish you had just look at this to
survive Raccoon City okay so select
herbs to mix I will select you and I
will wait
Russian accent alright okay I understand
now I guess and then place it in a
tablet case so the tablet case is
essentially your quick select that you
don't to go into your iPod menu for our
iPhone whatever that note 7 is girl take
some of these pills I'm just talking
about how much denominations have died
here today
you're not gonna list I just talked
about how much he looks like tests from
the beginning of the last of us oh yeah
girl you mean Boston
that guy up to
I could have been shooting this fool
ages ago
[Laughter]
so it begins we are gonna jump into
Leon's campaign first stuff if I didn't
mention that already are two I did such
a good job stabbing that guy in the head
yeah we figured we give Chris a break
after the arduous journey that resonable
five wasn't and also just can't let your
guard down for a second
Lance campaign is more survival-horror
than Chris is according to Capcom
survival-horror how do you feel great I
think I'm gonna be okay my hair's really
greasy though we're heading to the quad
Tower they yeah the whole concept of
pills yeah I just looked the other way
on because they don't make any sense I
can't abandon them oh that he like has
an invisible mortar and pestle that who
grinds these plants and dangles with
yeah like rubs them into your like
bullet wound or but like it's been like
that since the beginning like I've just
chosen to look the other way so long
that's not fair well point to be like
that's silly I always imagine girl from
like rubbing the leaf into the wound
within their older games and then in the
Fellowship of the Ring that's what our
horn does with a is that how you come to
terms with it you're like in Lord of the
Rings yeah I saw it
yeah shove the leaf in there rubs Ethel
Ison to photos mortal blade wound to
stop him from becoming a rape
they're poison or whatever
oh my goodness I forget where you are
Shanghai this doesn't look like Shanghai
you been to Shanghai I've seen photos
just start spamming are too if you want
are to my old the old kick them until
their head falls off this is such a
silly thing you want some of this but
how about it it's like the kick that you
have some fighters do so like we can
know if their opponent's life a
hamstring thing you can use health right
now probably Oh
oh wait done kick she looks like Tomb
Raider put those khakis on t-shirt
I just look like a badass is that gonna
be me then you'll be the lady yeah Elena
Harper -
wait where's my girlfriend's supposedly
in front of you probably I feel like she
was injured things already here
I'm back hey fast forwarded the mic
machines they knew were such big fans
hey you keep thinking I'm dead but in
fact here I am chop her and everything
hey Mikey let's get a beer when we get
back
oh it's not Mikey Zomba oh my goodness
little while
and this rights okay I need you to take
off who takes off the plane while
they're dead
take off your dead that mean okay
[Music]
oh [ __ ] what it's a perfect opportunity
for me to shoot him like normal style
you know like with my gun
like I understand cuties for things like
dodging a train or something weird but
it's like we're shooting a gun I already
have a button for that yeah agency but
nope this campaign is not all about that
oh man this is just like that scene in
Jurassic Park - yeah you know time out
yeah it'd be that'd be pretty terrifying
on the bus yeah
I wonder which one came first I always
worry about stuff like that when I see
things like this a spark - whoa dress
apart - by a long shot
this was like five years ago dress part
two was you thought a lost world yeah
the one with um Jeff Goldblum Joe life
finds away guy yeah no that was first
alright we still open doors the same old
way hey cha that's what my penis is
shaped like shouldn't us be in
Washington not me leon's talking here
penis not me Leon you have the ability
to end this prologue right now you're
lingering on my is that the joke no
Mikey was was better he's dead check his
pulse
i watch Tropic Thunder reasoning again
twice back for more hey what sweet I
haven't seen Tropic Thunder in a really
long time but it's pretty funny cool so
I think
tinta Tintin okay I hope so I've never
done this before but I looked it up and
I think all we have to do is screen mode
split okay so wait which campaign did
you select man okay yeah we start with
Leon all right
give Chris a break and then difficulty
normal and screen mode split right split
even online this isn't gonna make it
like oh I don't know I don't know so
single then I did split I think that
would make more sense and then pick Leon
I'll take Elena and then okay wait oh no
I don't know if this works so we do a
few single I think dude do we need to do
this online like we can do this on one
PlayStation like you could put your
controller on my playstation okay do
that so we decided not to do that in
five because then it would just clutter
the whole it does clutter but some
people like to see what you're up to
because I am better than you hey we're
back we've never left I'm gonna and I
had to restart my ps4
[Music]
hey who's that guy mr. president good
timing
[Music]
leave the room I mean he's obviously not
the president get off my plane
[Music]
she has the same outfit as Sebastian
Castellanos from the evil within yeah
she looks like talking about this is
your fault stabbed him with a syringe
that said zombie maker on it I didn't
know what it would do
Cathedral I'll explain everything there
at Kennedy wait aren't they friends you
don't know me you've nothing my penis
I'm again are we going back in time yes
we know each other
Oh Rosie Oh for oh yeah on your
situation
don't they flirt
I wonder if it worked out never kid
together that's her I just shot the
president what a way to frame it right
up front I just shot the president my
life I don't want you to worry about it
but I totes shot the Prez he did he did
nothing to cushion that blow no like or
like the president is a zombie and then
I shot him like they didn't like explain
it sorry I spaced out while we talk for
a second oh my god is that the president
who did this if you come with me wow
there's a smoldering look I'll go with
you
this president would
still make a better one than drum ooh
I'm sorry
political no I'm just kidding but
seriously so what's so special about
this church
I wish right before you shot him he was
like you are being impeached or
something cool that you'd say to a
president right why should I move oh
this art this feels so floaty what do
you mean they're making us move slowly
like the movement just feels floating I
also I cannot lift my gun no matter what
I do I'm only restricted to moving
forward and leaning on this door yeah no
I got stripes on my sleeves you doing a
Sikh biker jacket this game is not
lacking in awesome outfits I was - this
is getting out of control you just shot
the president was it under control
already huh when the president died
everything wasn't that great but now
it's really crazy that would be so
[ __ ] sweet if that was the last line
of the game after 28 hours this is
getting out of control
now I'm upset it's not working this is
only just beginning
can I open it why the [ __ ] do they cover
the Ivy University with elevator floor
indicators I don't know maybe like it's
trying to show this is an old building
that they have since I don't think
got some sick stuff this is a cool intro
area because because it reminds me of
the mansion yeah like I know it's not
but it just has they're doing that Gears
of War thing though and they're trying
to dialogue and make you walk slower hey
I can walk what are they serving what is
that soap a weird cupcake pizza pastry
cupcake pizza what was that hold on
let's what was that what are they going
for cupcake pizza yeah I don't know like
bruschetta
that's just squares of colors that's
food food can be like that
these balloons are oddly spherical
you're getting distracted get over here
you see one of them aim for the head
it's your best bet I got it is this his
inauguration no I think it's uh this is
where the reception was was this his day
of retirement it'd all be here actually
damn it
that president was one day away from
retirement shoot him in the head
yeah his 401k and shoot him in the face
like raccoon talk about social security
you have like 10 you just go you got one
per episode feel kind of bad room
talking over this dialogue but I also
have don't I'm not really sure what's
going on it's probably because we're
talking over the dialogue yeah I mean
this game is is this like five where
they keep where they keep saying you'll
find out soon enough
yeah how are you doing what was her name
yeah booby McGee
Melania whatever her name is Melania
[Music]
Adam yeah I think he was just speaking
at a commencement reception though
wonder what like who got married Oh what
did you scare yourself you stared
what's going on you're in the way again
the back Hey look squares is that [ __ ]
oh there's a chicken I'm not sure what
this is a PlayStation 4 we're playing on
what is that like sriracha sauce next to
a watermelon flavored ice cream cake I
think that in the middle um what are
those things that make your pee smell
funny asparagus that's asparagus love
asparagus and I love the way it makes my
pee smell but I think it's lasagna maybe
or like a weird square burrito I mean
this one is a lasagna with meat like a
tuba meeting them at home yeah they
didn't really uh Perez the meat in this
game I'm looking in this meat cause
right here no it's well prepare to a
full lifetime of being disappointed in
me well that's the prologue showed us
Lord
oh they got away with going over here
I'm the mr. vice president president's
daughter
the fog it came out of nowhere
whiz wait let me go to Pinterest
my daughter she's all alone if we don't
do something right I get it if you don't
keep it down you won't live to save her
you understand my daughter my daughter
my daughter wait who is this um it's the
vice president also known now as the
president looks like Tony Shalhoub let's
find her from monk Leone we don't have
time to making the time Oh
executive decision okay I'm actually
serious I miss who this guy as I forgot
I played this game in 2000 I don't
really think they explained it sorry
dude oh that was louder than my gun what
the [ __ ]
sorry you're scared I'm not scared rats
oh look how many there are
this cake thing you're you are 100%
right that looks like asparagus and
limes on top notes alright get away from
my focus oh wait where did this guy go
where did he go how do you set your
flashlight on there it's natural
no it's like connected to my head look
why don't I have one I do feel like this
guy should like let me go first because
I have a gun oh because the game's not
making him I don't feel like that's
building the atmosphere that it thinks
we didn't start the fire just stay close
studebaker Richard Nixon Marilyn on bow
come on little man couldn't pop it with
a gun bullet no I did look look look
president Adam Benford wait what did
that say our nation's future the youth
of America mmm interesting oh here we go
be delivering a speech to America's
students it was literally just speech
I'm sorry we I need your help do you oh
you idiot open up the door all right so
you've played this before
so what's the money that she's a Zambo
what's doing what you all right
and she will be once I find my daughter
yes yeah I called her cell but what we
could cut off I know she's here
somewhere
Liz its pop-pop that's what uh we'll
need to get the elevator whirling Dennis
Reynolds from It's Always Sunny called
their grams lock pop-pop take my car
yeah I feel like you can't undo that
let's find Lizzy get the hell out of
here very well
Liz this is that you it's like a bloody
sheet that doesn't even look close to a
daughter let's be fair
who's playing the piano
a little [ __ ] finger fingers on it
kick it open in that cool way that you
do yeah they're doing everything for me
I almost shot you you idiot you eat them
she's not doing great escape from the
campus we're on campus just take four
years and study really hard mission
accomplished
escape from campus sounds like a really
sad game Friday 13 I'm like level seven
you have a biology teacher who's just a
huge dick
evylyn in two comes out on Friday 13th
in October oh yeah I like that game I
like like two-thirds of it a lot the
less was it the ending yep there's
fifteen chapters I loved I liked the
first ten I remember you telling me this
oh so for the record when you're aiming
you can click right analog to let's get
this end up it's your other shoulder so
obviously like for the purpose of the
stream that'll put your phone under the
our hip but I guess definitely matter
that much I don't think people really
need to see your smartphone at all times
I'm glad you guys were here to hold
these two by fours
you couldn't definitely not have crawled
okay hold let's hold on a second turn
around look at this whoo barricades a
door by putting a lumberyards worth of
wood on how are these cardboard boxes
okay
oh it's let's go um like 62 by fours on
cardboard boxes yeah but also whoo
how do you lure it up a door you take
that long to board it up you don't these
armies are strong did they not have any
nails yeah I don't know
she's obtuse ami
say your goodbyes shoes he like school
staff I guess I'm super did Leon
experienced enough to know she's going
to come back seriously like is he gonna
act surprised what a good like cry face
I know his daughter just died what your
daughter's number cherry no zombie oh
[Music]
[ __ ] she being eaten well not that
shocking about me Oh
nice job snitches get stitches I'll have
what she's having
yes we'll get used to it it's either
them or us I love the smell morning if
you're not gonna eat it you can wear it
I don't know
clean-up on aisle 7 actually whatever I
got it let's make like a tree and yep
okay did you see what I did to that dude
no it's like a [ __ ] Trinity from the
matrix you amen watch watch watch
okay wait that guy's no he's not alive
all right do it well I mean oh [ __ ] I'm
doing it the wrong way should we just
run or Zhanna kick don't know I'm
missing Chino chop oh what's that do
that again okay so when you're aiming
press X yeah you look stupid doing it
yeah no yeah oh this is stupid let's go
what's move i'm keep your head on a
swivel I'm faster than you
wait how did you I'm not telling you
plain crab soccer Maya Cavs edge this is
the only way to deal with it this is
like what dogs do when they're [ __ ]
it you're all boots Koontz this guy gets
it figured it out you had to do it okay
see this is
how do they know that where I don't know
and they took the time to make the sign
when they could be running look behind
you
let's go Leon it's too late we can do
they they have a sign that says help on
it just to piss everyone off I'm gonna
do a video about why this game is
actually brilliant I want to see a
reboot reboot episode on why res six is
the best res that'd be a sick heartache
and by that I mean five years after it
comes out ground zero six still better
than reso seven no you have to open it
up like everyone was hoping that they
could fix the series at seven but the
truth is that everyone's dumb it was
never broken to begin with mm-hmm
and you keep stirring you keep cutting
to black I'm sort of fine
like randomly even if you don't say
anything cool like you're dying feeling
about this pretty good I got it
[Laughter]
the best one wait where are we going
this it's a dead end anyway
Oh oh [ __ ] other way oh wait no press
backwards really quick do a real boot
scoot actually yeah yeah oh that's
actually kind of cool when you aim in
the press back and acts like your dive
backwards I might use that actually a
few times it's pretty funny Oh election
policy some kids just slug in beers
during geography didn't mean to
interrupt
well it's your fault I had a rush last
night for Sai Omega Phi did you get hurt
no oh it's go please no problem girl
I didn't reload because I have an extra
bullet squared I am going to stop Eve
you always a fire [ __ ] okay this way
that is cool
if you shoot this dis cans come out like
NCS but there's not even a place to your
cans to come out NCS no like in CS I
thought you said where are the cans TV
showing tell me where the cans come out
that's a very good question
this machine is broken and whoever
designed it is stupid they thought to
put the lock but not yeah you can see
where their time went that's the one I
was talking oh that's cool I'm very
impressed with you it's not the game's
lack of style over criticizing it's just
it's tiered attention to weird detail
oh there's a plant back here where
there's a plant okay all right wait so
we have independent loot drops I forgot
so I also got a plan
oh really yeah that's weird for this
game okay okay so put that in the tablet
remember to put it in your capsule to
each press r1 right I was going to
convince before I put it in a capsule or
does that not matter he was like there's
no cans in here actually
maybe it's because five boys jumped over
room you see that cuz no maybe it's
because radio 505 is so I've started a
sentence sometimes I'm sorry the
previous game in this series is so like
sun-drenched that I actually kind of
liked this art direction despite the
fact that nothing makes sense it looks
it's a pleasant departure from under 30
circle I don't think a lot of people had
complaints about the art direction no
probably not I just I'm just saying it's
even more refreshing as five or so wait
wait can I do that I wanted to I shot
him in the ass
how do you do that thing where you do
like the suplex around it's a matter of
which part of their body you do it to
like you have to come up to like his
side maybe or you have to do it when
they're stumbling or something but it's
r2 right yeah it's like a kick it's like
a fancy kick yeah it's like a grapple
but I think you have to do it either
when they're like stunned or stumbling
Oh a bunch of them right there go get
that girl which one brainerd okay maybe
I had to be how do you sprint it's X
right
here we go
I don't know try it on those dudes I
don't know I'm really good at these
roundhouse kicks I see me roll out of it
though
I forget why the skill points are just
oh I got hurt yeah in my back I'm fine
I have hell I have health so that's also
weird so tell me how the health works
yeah you can combine them in um like
what's my health right now is it three
it's at three and then under that is why
is it all white it's just always gonna
be white I guess it's just okay
obviously so I can combine this with
this and then I put this in my pocket
and now it's in a quick know if you're
actually combining them yeah I guess you
are so then when you do oh yeah so you
can heal more than one so if I do yeah
okay I just used one that did one bar so
yeah maybe combining them you can learn
it oh there's somehow an election here
it's a new scent coming
I really hate that it's circle to save
your partner not just are to like the
other no I want the ammo it only lets me
jump over oh wait I'm done
it's like an instant oh so this is where
weapons okay so I don't have a shotgun I
have a double girl shotgun - I
you have another repress left [ __ ] and
then I think bear with me just watching
him sorry can I not wow so I can't just
quit
oh yeah I get to press down for grenades
and help
okay so items is down and up weapons are
left and right that's got it okay I
understand yeah you're at half health so
you might want to use that okay actually
yeah I'm curious press r1 it might use
all three and just refill your health
really curious wait what Express r1 I
want to see what those
[Music]
today what's the point of combining them
cuz that didn't do anything different
well I got three did you get three no
you only got that only replenish one no
I'm saying I have three yeah you got
three two well I got three scalp no
you're at three now at four sorry let me
be clear I have three of these right and
if you get three of them - no I only
have one but you used one and I used one
of it but I'm saying as I had to and I
combined them so I got three of these oh
it just increases the number of them you
have okay it's not actually okay sorry
I'm being dumped no it's fine [ __ ] I was
not doing a very good job of explaining
that I was trying I want to stab someone
really badly oh my God look how big
these sushi rolls are hold on you have
to see this this is important wait what
are these sushi rolls are the slide
coming okay [ __ ] plates oh my god
wait maybe they're not sushi that's
clearly supposed to be sushi you know
those things that people make when they
put a bunch of [ __ ] in tortillas and
then they roll them up and cut them into
slices very valid but that's not the red
ones might be like a like a tomato
sun-dried tomato wrap these are
definitely sushi like look we're gonna
rice the seaweed [ __ ] a little bit of
cucumbers salmon I would say tuna I
don't know that's sujin I love how okay
we're going this way
oh [ __ ] wait
oh my god this is so much oh there's an
herb over here for me I got I stopped
calling out items I guess it's
independent but they're probably using
that oh that was green herb ooh red herb
okay so let me figure this out so
combine that with that crack oh it gives
you six yes okay cool I see what you're
saying yes oh sweet okay the teacher has
become stupid honey game can you open it
key card from here such a thinking
person's game
try the staff building behind the
bleachers okay so you'll find keys for
the gate there oh this is where he gave
his speech okay oh okay
man he breeds a lot or loudly with I
guess he's running he's working around
the next corner
I'm so [ __ ] cool wait hold on oh you
pick up ammo while you're aiming and
criminally wait did you do that yeah
hormones yeah you were just over it no
I'm dumb it's weird popping up at the
bottom here well I'll check this [ __ ]
out that is cool wait I'll watch your
stick you go it's gonna be alive wait I
got it
wait there's ammo over here well yeah
that's one saying like we're seeing
different ammo drops but it might be in
the same area
great job dum-dum the doors locked
there's no way out oh it's a football
field right next to it orange mascot we
have a grenade should we use it
where the [ __ ] did that guy come from
oh [ __ ] I didn't need to do that I'm
stupid get oh my god why do they keep
hitting us with
we gotta get out of here
[Music]
yeah behind in that time fist up
president all right
oh we don't have to do it like it's no
electronic lock but also
oh [ __ ] I have a side of it that I might
[ __ ] up no I got it holy [ __ ]
okay we good dad was it an electron for
this medieval [ __ ] beerus yeah I didn't
I didn't do so hot sweet so you gain
health back that's what it looks like to
me I mean over time I got some health
back without healing yes basically it
was in the red and I got that one back
let me just trip over all their bodies
how's the view from your side my back
yet just give me a second cheapest okay
I'm done it's like that thing blue does
great rips us back on they did that on
proven I got a remote bomb I need to use
my grenades this happens every time
we're we're like in a situation and I'm
like this is a really good situation for
grenades so we have a 140 handguns oh I
don't have nearly that much I was using
my shotgun during that I'm all knife
wait what was that that's cool get nice
in your space
geez that took a long time it's weird
that kicking someone is more efficient
than knifing room just [ __ ] dropping
okay so we're going home yes why why am
i oh so that's like in dirt oh I want to
do that again I feel like I could do
this yes it looks so [ __ ] cool
rolling to freedom
died that's actually that's kind of cool
you are so annoying you could shoot like
they have a one hand you could shoot it
wow that's cool I'm a cool I mean
surprisingly adequate for this game
let's go alright
oh look the quick turns back is it weird
for you that you can move while you're
anything in this game have you I adapted
really well because it's modern I think
it was the first time I'd be like what
listen I better go off on gunner because
I haven't done oh it's not a good thing
right but we have this gate right yeah
what is that oh it's just lets me go
over it I understand
can those people break that oh this
school looks pretty [ __ ] up to begin
with
I don't know oh I see somebody not a lot
we got
I [ __ ] kicked you like 10 times oh
that's pretty cool you missed that but
that was really cool I
I killed them against the fence how neat
is that the answer is that's the second
time I shot that man while he's flying
I think we should run I think you just
found our ride out of here
Timmy no keys
you're doing a quick 10 minute to start
a car at resolute
I can't do [ __ ] right good glove
compartment this is look up at the visor
I think this is so down police on oh
sorry
I just like to drive this to be honest
with you like the way normal people
drive cars I'm not driving less and it's
a huge bummer crash looks like we just
graduated get me out of here have some
snacks just leave us alone into the
garbage we be worried all that the
covers already removed how do I get in
circled somewhere on the other side of
the day
up up there you go
why did I wait for you yes you get a
buff I get a buff from you that lets me
jump could be a time to end it my guess
was that an hour yeah
probably almost with us technical
difficulties JUnit should hurry what's
the matter
there's nothing weird dr. Soares no do
you not just hear that it's the
cathedral and then I'll tell you
everything everything we know about the
Raccoon City incident but Sir a lot of
people are questioning my desire to
reveal the truth
we knew Ted and might create more
problems than it solves a lesson I
learned well in the military and they
really spent way less time on his facial
model than Leon's bio-organic weapons
are a global threat got those sucked in
cheeks we have to come clean only what
they do with evil people
whatever you decide sir mr. president
with you I just want you to know that
I'll never shoot you oh wait so is this
Ashley Grahams dad responsibly I think
from oh that makes sense
wait if this is Ivanka dad oh my god I
was right all along
we good it's gonna be a tough road Fitz
those are stairs
let's get moving sweet all right yay not
for us
I know yeah
end game session all unsafe progress
will be lost let's hope so I just ended
it
spoilers spoilers
okay we'll see you it's definitely
residue er Knievel
it's sewer six I can see it boiling it
this sewer